Speaker 1: We're continuing to speak to people in
the audience, you really make the show what it is.
If it weren't for you, I would just
be a guy in a room with a microphone
talking to nobody. So you're making this
situation much less sad that you're there.
Let's talk next to oh, I don't know. Let's go to
Marc from Dublin now. Is this Dublin, Ireland, of
or one of the many Dublin's in the United States,
Speaker 3: as is Dublin, Ireland. All right. Well,
hello. Welcome. Welcome. Hi, so I was wondering
what your thoughts are on Trump's immigration
policy compared to Obama's immigration policy?
I think you and I would both agree that
whilst Trump is a lot worse than Obama and Biden,
neither are as progressive as we would like. And
I believe that Obama deported more people than
any previous president. So how do you think we
can critique Trump's immigration policy
and retaining the big picture of systemic
issues with the American immigration policy?
Speaker 1: Well, I think the systemic issue is
that the the there's a couple of systemic issues,
and neither Trump nor Obama solve them. And we
could argue about to what degree did they make
them worse or do nothing about it or fix them
a little. One is the overwhelming focus on the
individuals who are in the United States illegally
versus cracking down on the
companies that continue to hire them,
cracking down on the companies that continue to
hire them. If you really want to like aside from
a guest worker program, whether it should be
illegal to just like whatever your views are,
the the lack of crackdown on the companies doing
the hiring continues to be one of the biggest
aggravating factors in the situation remaining
what it is. Obama didn't fix that and Trump didn't
fix that. I think Trump showed even less interest
than Obama did in dealing with that. So that's
one thing. I think that's a fair critique. Number
two, you know, DACA is a massive issue. Some kind
of permanent solution to DACA seems to be in the
top three issues when it comes to immigration.
And that continues to be an issue. And we can
continue to criticize for the lack of a of a
permanent solution there. So I agree with you
that President Obama left much to be desired
when it when it comes to immigration.
Trump really scaled up one of the most
outwardly despicable aspects which were, you know,
the family separations and the so-called kids in
cages. And I know the counter is that that also
existed under Obama. I wouldn't deny that. But
scaling that up in conjunction with this very
xenophobic, motivated, I call it for shorthand,
a majority Muslim country. And I think there's
certainly more criticism of Trump than of Obama,
although there's plenty to criticize of both.
Speaker 3: OK, fair. What are some specific
policies under Trump that you
think made him particularly bad,
just the scaling up or their additional policies?
Speaker 1: Well, so, again, a lot of what Trump
did wrongly on immigration is not just the scaling
up of the separations and kids in cages. It was
also using the pandemic to very cynically be able
to do more deportation under the guise of public
health, while clearly not actually caring about
it, using the doc, the lack of DACA resolution
as a sort of stick with which to bully people.
I mean, it he didn't pass that much policy other
than the majority Muslim country ban. It
was sort of the totality of his rhetoric,
his cynical use of the pandemic to continue
a xenophobic immigration policy. You know,
all these things together, it's less about
here's the laws he signed, the bills he signed.
Speaker 3: OK, OK, OK. So it's also how he
enforce the laws that. Indeed, indeed. OK,
ok. Yeah. Well, thanks for taking my
call. Appreciate speaking with you again.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Thank
you so much for calling in.